[Music]
[Music]
greetings
we're truly excited to share with you
everything that's coming to hearthstone
this year
but first let's take a quick look back
at the year
of the phoenix we added our first new
class
the demon hunter and vented into the
ruthless outlands
then we went to scholomance academy and
got to explore
dual class cards and their powerful
synergies
and with our third expansion of the year
we bought hearthstone's biggest
update ever alongside the menacing old
gods
in madness at the dark moon fair we
launched a brand new game mode
duels that saw more than 10 million
matches on its first day
we also introduced our long-awaited
achievement system
and made a significant overhaul to the
rewards and progression within the game
now it's time to say farewell to the
year of the phoenix
and see what's in store for hearthstone
this year
welcome to the year of the griffin
over the last couple of years we've made
big changes to hearthstone
throughout the year of the griffin we
want to keep delivering
fun new experiences and make sure
that the tens of millions of you playing
hearthstone
are always excited to log in first up
we'll be giving the standard format its
biggest shakeup ever
with the launch of the core set later
this year
the corset replaces the old basic and
classic sets
with a collection of 235 cards
made up of some of the best from
throughout the years
as well as 29 awesome brand new cards
and the best thing about the corset is
that it's entirely free
so there's never been a better time
to get into hearthstone here are three
of hearthstone's
legendary dragons reimagined to feel
more up-to-date
and competitive for modern-day
hearthstone
yasera the dreamer you'll finally
receive her
full arsenal of dream cards right away
she's a nightmare for your opponents
malygos the spellweaver he'll fill your
hand with spells
and is a powerful late gameplay
worthy of the aspect of magic
and finally everyone's favorite black
dragon
deathwing he's still as destructive as
ever
but timed correctly he won't leave you
empty-handed
we'll also be launching a brand new
format
classic where you can play hearthstone
as it was
when it first launched the classic
format will be
fully supported complete with ranks and
rewards
using hearthstone's original set of
cards
so if you want to relive the old school
experience
then classic is the place for you with
classic revisiting the past
now let's take a look to the future and
explore the first expansion
of the year of the griffin
for a hero of the horde
all roads lead to the crossroads
you have come for adventure
but the barons wants to break you
and your heart must be
mighty
this is who we are
that's right we're headed to one of
warcraft's most iconic locals
the barons and will come face to face
with the heroes that inhabit it
starting with one of the horde's most
iconic and well-known characters
a fierce loyalist one-time warchief that
embodies the
honor loyalty and spirituality
of the horde shadowhunter vol'jin
shadowhunter vulgin is a neutral
legendary that allows you
to either bolster your own board or
weaken that of your opponents
and to celebrate the announcement of
forged in the barons
this card is available for free for
everyone
later today so log in to hearthstone and
claim your free copy
of shadowhunter vol'jin and
as a bonus we're also giving away
the brand new 30 years of blizzard card
back
next we have another hero of the horde
who is making his
first appearance in hearthstone
the legendary blademaster samurai
featuring the new keyword frenzy
frenzy activates the first time a minion
takes down
and survives in samuro's case this can
be used
to clear your opponent's board heroes of
the horde like samara are famous for
their combat prowess
but others like thrall are known for
their powerful elemental magic
[Music]
take a look at this new shaman spell
chain lightning
chain lightning is a spell in a new
cycle of cards
that rank up and become more powerful
when you have five
and ten mana ensuring that they're
always useful
at every stage in the game
you'll also notice that they're
categorized as nature spells
with thoughts in the barons we'll be
permanently introducing spell schools
across the entire game which enables a
whole host of exciting
new strategies and don't worry members
of the alliance
will be featuring some of your most
beloved heroes and locales
later this year but
what i love most about the warcraft
universe is its amazing characters
and our final announcement is our most
ambitious addition to hearthstone yet
it introduces a brand new way to play
with your favorite heroes
hearthstone mercenaries
mercenaries features strategic rpg
gameplay
where you build teams consisting of some
of the most iconic
heroes and villains from the warcraft
universe
including timeless characters like the
infamous sylvanas windrunner and
ragnaros the elemental lord of fire
you can also expect to see some of
hearthstone's fan favorites
like the unstoppable devil saw king
crush
and the ever-growing gruel the dragon
slayer
you'll lead them in battle through
highly replayable
rogue-like missions where the map is
randomly generated
every time you play and each node
represents a unique
challenge for your team's take on your
heroes gain levels
new abilities equipment and can even
evolve
into more powerful versions of
themselves
we're thrilled to finally show you
hearthstone mercenaries
it is scheduled to launch later this
year and
we'll have more to share with you down
the road
everything you've seen today is just a
taste of what's coming in the year of
the griffin
so don't forget to tune in to our deep
dive panel after the opening ceremony
where we'll share more details on the
corset
the new classic format forged in the
barons and our plans for battlegrounds
and jewels
as well as our upcoming single-player
content
i want to thank the team for their
amazing work and on behalf of all of
us at hearthstone we want to thank the
many millions of you who play our game
your dedication and support is what
drives us to make
awesome updates and pursue ambitious and
fun
ideas we can't wait to kick off the year
of the gryphon with all of you
and we hope to see you in the game soon